and I'm definitely with and we're
excited / a little bit nervous to have
you guys here with us you should be
we've got the cast of Impractical Jokers
here with us I'm worried that you guys
gonna play a prank on us well I'm like
this is why I'm on this side we already
have yeah go figure it out we've
obviously got this awesome fan Jenga in
front of us that we're gonna play with
you guys in just a little bit but before
we get to that you guys are in your
fifth season of the show right now and
you just announced yesterday that you've
got a six keep coming up with prank Oh
mortgage bills
yeah you see the bill and we need to
come up with what right if it comes down
to it I'll punch him square in the face
that's what friends are for like I gotta
pay my mortgage I don't watch you when
you're walking around comic-con do you
got me you're get brains are always
working obviously prank and pregnant
have you ready set out who's getting
pranked the comic-con have you done them
already I'm or we gonna see them yeah we
prank skew this morning we messed him up
as the Joker who made him close talk
people trying to get them to see I'm
trying to get a date to go see suicide
school yeah he was not dateable no he
looked better dressed as a joker did you
go to up to any Harley Quinn's did you
get any harm I'm great I was like that's
that's your target audience yeah yeah
okay well that's a follow-up question I
want to ask you guys out of all the
superheroes out there who do you guys
think would be the most fun to prank and
why Oh doctor strange strange why
absolutely how come cuz the name is just
perfect the prank okay that's the doctor
strangest thing I've ever seen happen oh
yeah I completely disagree with his
selection yeah I would say a spider oh
boy yes my little minor boys great
spider boy by the boy because he's like
you know a super face no way sure enough
yeah he's a super face your face is
right yeah
I go Captain jean-luc Picard yes yeah
over here oh yeah okay taking about yeah
he is a superhero okay my mom because
she's my superhero love you [ __ ] oh we
live V I love you buddy
but that's an any super baby super B
it's a pretty badass nickname yeah yeah
uh we're just kind of talking about that
do you guys ever feel like there is a
line because obviously you see pranks
gone wrong where you guys are saying
you'll punch each other in the face but
sometimes you freak somebody out and
they react negatively do you have a line
where you're like now we're not gonna go
that far Jenna that's a demo we have
some big bills to pay mark now we draw
the line on the show that's all the
whole part of it if we say no to
something is that's too much we can do
that but then at the end we get punished
and it's a horrible fate but I kind of
gives you the motivation to push it as
far as you can but for the most part
we're throwing each other under the bus
not really like trying to mess with
anyone do you rather original punishment
that we came up with that we that we
actually submitted to the network for
the treatment was we would go to a
stranger's wedding and when someone says
does anyone here object
you'd have to stand up right go into
this long story about why you object
realize you're at the wrong wedding
apologize and leave one day yeah well
that's the thing will you guys just
there's a lot of there's a lot of prank
but what you guys do is you add your
humor you can see what the dynamic - and
that was when you went into doing this
it was just play on the dynamic add the
humor and prank each other right what I
what does that kind of separate you from
kind of doing the other P etter doing we
didn't want to do a typical prank show
we wanted to do our spin on it in the
spin we came up with by the way I'm
gonna you guys are both very
knowledgeable informative or so and I
appreciate that side know also both very
attractive in your own right our own
right so what that means that means that
you're better looking but he's being
nice put together you're beautiful no
you are look at me this is this is a
Maronna database target like a seven box
loser there's a reason why they put us
behind the camera we're only good from
here oh this is all I'm working with you
got me lower than this look at you look
at me
look at me anyways the twist is that the
joke is on us it's friendship right yeah
we quickly said we shouldn't do that the
wedding because really marriage as an
institution is antiquated and love
doesn't really exist I love my wife so
the way I love married and I love my
wife right probably ouch one question
for you guys what was your favorite
prank that you guys have film so far in
all your season at this point there's
been so many like rue would you get out
that look that wasn't yours talked about
one one six out of my mind it's some
season two we worked as dentist yes we
don't know what to do continue I'll be
back okay yeah okay
anyways so well we were his dentist and
Sal was in the dentist and he had a
patient in the in the dentist chair he's
tickling Murray speak and and we told
him to recline the guy upside down in
the dentist's chair of the patient I get
a serious conversation so Wow good Chi
rebuilds headphones get a bone and
you're gonna head bow thank you I went
down to the basement they have a whole
shipment out limited you guys could say
hey I just found my dog I'll be there
okay yeah every box should we get to the
games I grab Hispanics yeah read that
he's holding up a sign I know that when
you're starting you start filming see
yeah well that's a great question you
came up with on all by yourself yeah hey
my stream was that all sorts of
questions coming I love it lawyers from
behind the bar in the meeting of energy
this fall we starts filming season six
we're very excited yeah yeah and then we
have a live event ax live the season
finale season five is like this live
huge to an hour spectacular yeah like
live like we're very good lot about
we're also super excited about being
here at comic-con because we're throwing
a huge block party at Petco Park
Oh tomorrow Saturday right from three to
eight thirty we're have this like five
thousand person who got it free we don't
want anything we don't have you know but
San Diego soon touring we tour every
weekend all over the world also anybody
that comes to the pickle park gets free
Fandango for a year it comes is cut you
have to just find me the screen just
like our guys you guys if you are just
joining us we are on Facebook live with
the cast of Impractical Jokers and right
now we said this before but we've got
fan jenga to play with you guys when we
did
a little bit different than regular
Jenga because each block has a question
on it the wrong yeah exactly we just
made it up um so when you pull the block
out that question that's on there is for
you specifically and then don't forget
to put the buck back on the top okay Wow
and when we pull we will ask someone
specifically it's fun all right come on
well I'm here summer you're up here we
go so do I do I do I be the jerk listen
to me lean against each other am I gonna
tell you what would it be the jerk
immediately would I'm gonna I'm gonna
destabilize the whole here's a joke
right
yeah all right okay boiler alert how
good is your Pope Pope up a poker face
how good is your poker today progress me
yeah George it's access really excellent
have a very good polite ready look at me
um you're really angry right now it's
pretty good all right that a little loud
I will go I will go so I got I got a
please yeah gotta put it back all right
I've played a game of Jenga that's
taking like 40 50 minutes I know let's
see I'm on the same side
yeah sure fun all right so is Sal
stand-up any good yeah I don't really
say that oh that's great Oh like oh you
better don't blow it is your plan Jabbar
uh yeah it's not he he answers the
question oh no no not for me
yeah yeah yeah you seen louis c.k yeah
nothing like that I'll say shall stand
up is very good that is getting sorry
fine sell Stan oh I'm all over town go
to shell stand up none more go to my
Twitter at Sal Vulcano and I tweet when
I'm gonna be somewhere office or I just
drop in and then it's like one for
everyone can oversee ourselves the guys
in TV wait can we just talk about the
fact that he was talking the whole time
didn't even pay attention and just pull
the ball that was good yeah I used to
work at a bar so we played this every
night well I can play them eyes closed
perfect I will I will from now on if it
gets back to me eyes closed are you guys
gonna be wowed all right well you can
put the eyes closed when you put it back
okay no however have you ever just
shushed someone in a movie theater
absolutely 100% I'll tell you right now
I am such a stickler I only go to
certain movie theaters and if I'm forced
to go to another one I go at off-peak
hours because I need my movie going
experience to stay where I needed to
turn your phone's off and uh put your
feet on the Jets right yeah although
sometimes the roles get reversed Sal got
shushed badly with spider-man turn up
the dark on Broadway yes you did drunken
you got sugar it's not a movie well
Broadway was exploited you selador
breadsticks make a whole scene so if
this guy shows to you in the movie don't
feel too badly right for syphilis all
right I'm on my own rules that is not
good man Jenga oh Jesus okay all right
looks like we got a game okay we got a
game to get in there I am yours early oh
wow no no I mean okay I already got is
there going to be an Impractical Jokers
moving ah certainly holy so we certainly
hope so I mean you know the movie biz
there's a thing about the biz that will
let you guys know about egg development
hell yeah it's really such a thing but
if when when it does come to fruition
I'm sure you could get tickets on
Fandango darker puss and I will not be
stretched in math ha ha ha
all right sheriff all right Joey Joey
say nada
you know the guy I don't know he's
wondering if he should dad I've
carefully sure how much longer do we
have of this game
about six more hours oh okay act like
it's third it's Thursday
act like this says some fact like shows
or something Oh got it
well now I run the whole thing all right
hold on everybody pretend rewind on your
live feed
Oh what do you read this is this is a
great one guy yeah do it to rethink the
movie tell me something oh my god that's
how they got to die that's how they and
that's all I got point one four five
prime numbers are very hard to put all
right I feel like I'm gonna blow it
oh they handle her oh yeah is someone
gonna throw this game because I'm gonna
play very competitively until we loose
Oh play to win I I will ask what is your
favorite movie quote oh that's a good
one it says a lot about you
oh I got uh oh my god Sunni okay yeah
yeah yeah um oh oh it's silly
okay how many what I don't think um I've
come here to chew bubblegum and kick ass
and I'm all out of bubble gerado class
I've also put the teddy bear back in the
box
that's all on air Nicholas Cage oh man
am i there no no surprise there it looks
good yeah that's good all right so who's
up who's I'm in alright you're up you're
up okay
oh man guys it's shaking a little right
here I could see I don't know it's not
going on it's not going we're gonna wish
dinosaurs existed well I mean they did
exist this used to be oh you mean now
yeah I know oh he's like a whip this guy
yeah although if I saw I don't know if I
saw a pterodactyl coming up what don't I
don't have to come say if you want to I
would die so you in want so you don't
want it to know you're afraid of spiders
I wonder you know I tell you though yeah
that'd be awesome see in some form I
mean right not in America
yeah well what does it meant to be a fun
light thing like you're really delving
into this right now let's play some
nutjob
yeah right am i havin in there oh good
you're up oh it's oh you are you up okay
okay all right no you ever fall this is
still very safe you went before me
tell your dad so guys listen I don't
want this hand badly I'm not trying to
you know go out of turn I'm not trying
to go out of turn here
all right go right there get on whatever
that's a laugh that's up that's how I'm
not gonna go right there at all tell me
what to do state without the boss of me
there we go hey Josh I what is your
social security number that's not fair
what is your go-to karaoke song oh
that's a good one I gotta say Whitney
Houston I want to dance with somebody
yes it gets good and young walk their
feet all the time everybody enjoys
especially the way I sing it Oh guys
that's it that's the game I really want
to let you guys know key Oh actually Oh
Sal Skylar Dawes asked before we let you
go Sal can you do the dance yes sure
I'm doing it right now from the bottom
hell what I could tell her I could do
they're not gonna see it but it coming
from here's a double dutch and it goes
like this and then you go down yeah go
to the front don't listen know it Skylar
on you or not the boss of me I rock guys
make sure important Jokers guys thank
you guys so much for joining us presents
for your loving what is it that will be
going on in the Bendigo studio here at
comic-con scream what's on social media
will see you leave your fan
you